je sais même pas pourquoi on fait ça
c'est pas un duo
tu as écrit une bonne chanson pas une
super chanson vous voulez qu'on
enregistre on continue à se battre les
deux me conviennent génial on va y aller
alors c'est
première prise
je peux te demander quelque chose à ton
avis de quoi ça parle tu veux que je te
dise de quoi ça parle que quoi la
chanson que j'ai écrite donc tu veux que
je te donne mon avis sur ma chanson
ça parle de commencer une nouvelle vie
[Musique]
j'ai toujours rêvé de quelque chose de
différent
[Musique]
je voulais dire bon c'est pas la peine
de s'engueuler
je voulais dire que j'adore le son de ta
voix
[Musique]
c'est votre premier 45 jours il est déjà
numéro 1 comment faire mieux que ça
[Applaudissements]
quand on fait un album c'est la team il
faut que ça soit je l'ai jamais vu aussi
souriant de toute sa vie
[Musique]
j'étais la première personne à qui tu
faisais entendre une chanson
[Musique]
c'est ce que le public veut voir c'est
du cinéma enfin tu sais bien
[Musique]
spécial entre nous voici
mais c'est amoureux si jamais ça
t'arrive ce sera fini entre nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dépensez pas qu'il serait temps
d'ajouter une petite flamme arrête d'y
penser c'est moi la flamme
[Musique]